Raúl Último Día de entrenamiento para
Argentina y para Croacia en la previa de
ese primer duelo de semifinales que este
martes Abre esta instancia en el estadio
de los usaid ambas selecciones que van a
entrenar a lo largo de la tarde aquí en
doha será un entrenamiento que contará
con la presencia de medios de
comunicación y también habrá rueda de
prensa con Argentina van a comparecer
tanto el seleccionador Lionel escaloni
como el defensa Nicolás atagliafico el
hombre llamado a ser titular para ese
Duelo contra los croatas por el lateral
izquierdo reemplazo de Marcos Acuña
suspendido en esa victoria de cuartos de
final contra los neerlandeses que
terminó con esa cifra recordé 16
tarjetas amarillas por parte de la otra
llave La de Francia y la de Marruecos
que juegan el miércoles en la otra
semifinal hoy Marruecos que entrena a
Puerta cerrada Francia si lo hará con
presencia de los medios y también habrá
comparecencia por parte del conjunto de
van a hablar Rafael baral y Jules
de hecho mientras que para un Pilar en
la defensa del capitán de esta saga que
ha sabido responder a estas exigencias
de la Copa mundo y vienen con mucho aire
en el pecho después de esa Victoria
contra Inglaterra como lo dijo Karen
Benzema están dos partidos más cerca de
cumplir ese objetivo y sin contar con
precisamente con la presencia del Balón
de oro